i'm going to tell you a story today
about archimedes this
wonderful mathematician of whom we know
not very much of all the ancient
mathematicians we know more about
archimedes than any of the others
but it's still not a lot
but we do know that he made incredible
discoveries
one of them was in exploring parabolas
now what's a parabola
that's a parabola that's another
parabola
a fountain creates parabolas you dive
off a diving board you fall in a
parabolic curve
and he wanted to know about parabolas
[Music]
archimedes would never have seen this
parabola they didn't have algebra in his
day
okay and they didn't have graphs in this
day however this is a parabola
and it's generated by this formula
y equals x squared and the y-axis is
going up ten times as fast
as the x-axis is going along so
y equals x squared so if x is 10
y would be 10 10 100 and that's there
corresponds to the y so all these dots
are generated like that and you've got a
parabolic curve
okay this is quite remarkable because
it's actually a calculator i'll show you
brady can you give me two numbers
less than 15. all right how about
12 and five okay 12 and 5.
so i'm going to put a line through the
12. that's it 5 and 12.
and then we'll put a line through there
it goes through 60
5 12 is 60. so this is an automatic
calculator isn't it great now this
parabolic curve is set in a rectangle
you can see
and what archimedes wanted to know was
if you put
a parabolic curve in a rectangle what's
the comparison between the area inside
the curve
and the area outside the curve what's
the ratio
he didn't know he wanted to find out and
he had a few tools
up his sleeve one thing he knew about
was the lever
and i'm going to make a lever this is a
normal ruler and i've balanced it
on the six inch mark so it balances and
if i take a domino
and put the domino on each end they will
balance them
they will both do it properly
they will balance okay look at that but
that's because at six
inches times one six inches times one
but you could do it with three dominoes
and make those balance by putting them
there
and that balances why because that's six
times one and that is two inches
times three two times three is six one
times six is six
so it bounces so he knew about levers
the other thing he knew about was
centers of gravity
he knew the center of gravity of a
triangle
and there i found the center of gravity
of this triangle you can try this with
any triangle you make doesn't have to be
a right angle
make it out of cardboard but as it work
all you do is you take the midpoint of
each side
and connect them to the angle opposite
and you'll get three lines that coincide
at one point
and that happens to be the center of
gravity
of the triangle and he knew about that
this was found or a version of this
founder can you see it's a little bent
triangle uh um galileo knew about this
so it's been around a long time
okay why was it on the skew
well i think is because can you see this
is a parabolic section
here and there's a triangle inside it
okay
now why is it on the skew he wanted to
show
that no a matter how you cut a slice
with a straight line
off a parabolic section if you have a
triangle inside it or a rectangle
outside it
the ratio is all the same and that's
what he was looking for
so i think that's why i put it on the
skew after he discovered it
so i've drawn it again here and you see
you've got a parabolic section with a
triangle inside it abc
so what's the ratio between the triangle
and the parabolic curve well i can put
that in a rectangle
which is twice the size of the triangle
same base
and same height so it's twice this
triangle
or i thought what i could do is actually
double the size of the triangle
doubling the height here with the same
base it must be
double the size of that triangle and ask
himself so what's the ratio between this
triangle
and the parabolic section or why don't i
go even further
why is it going further i'll explain
that later why don't we go even further
he said and double the light of that so
we've doubled that
we've doubled that drawn that here and
now
this triangle twice the height
same base so it's four times that
triangle
in size what is the ratio in area
between that
and the parabolic section well that's
where he got to
so where did he go to next he used the
tools he already understood about
he used the lever so he took the same
diagram and doubled the length of this
i named that point f why
because it sounds a fulcrum and he
wanted to make a seesaw balance
there and then
he took a line just dropped it down m-o
and found that that line where it
crossed the parabolic section
he called p-o and he thought about this
wouldn't it be lovely if a lion had
weight
hang on hang on where are we going we
know from geometry
that the shortest distance between two
points is a straight line
which has no width so it can't have
weight
but he said what if it had
and what if i dropped every conceivable
mo
down this triangle until i blotted it
out with ink
and it had weight now for every mo
there's a po that crosses the parabolic
section
why don't you take all those pos
and put them on here at the end of my
balance
would it balance this triangle that's
still there
and he said i bet it does but it would
only balance
out the balance point which is the
center of gravity of this triangle
which is two-thirds to one-third along
there
two-thirds to one-third along there and
two-thirds to one-third along there
point x and it should balance
which means can you see because that's
only one third
that's three times as far so this
triangle must weigh
three times as much as the parabolic
section
so half of it must weigh one and a half
times as much of the parabolic section
so half of that must mean that the
triangle abc
is three quarters the area of the
parabolic section
and he was right
incredible intellect from an absolute
genius
[Music]
the quite amazing thing about this is
what
archimedes gave a line weight right and
decided all those lines
would equal the triangle and gave them
weight but what it was doing
was actually inventing calculus whereby
you measure
tinier and tinier pieces put them all
together
but calculus wasn't going to be invented
for another 2000 years
and carl friedrich gauss said oh the
idiot
he discovered calculus and he let it go
through his fingers
so sad and 2 000 years earlier than
anybody else
this video was supported by brilliant
look at so hard choosing which
mathematics or science caused to choose
when you log into brilliant
today let's go for some geometry
fundamentals
now look i'm glad you watched number
five videos but there's something next
level about
answering questions and actually
interacting with the stuff on the screen
like this brilliant is lovingly designed
and everything's so clean simple clever
really love it now to check out more go
to brilliant.org
number file that slash number file lets
them know you came from here
and perhaps more importantly gets you 20
off a premium subscription
and remember if and when you finally
finish with all this geometry
there's so much more to do
i've color coded it for different places
that i've lived
because in my memories you know i kind
of like almost catalog things that way
you know so this is you know until i was
eight years old i lived here in torrance
and then i moved to
brea both those were in california you
know and then this is like college